[Music]
This is I'd Like to Know, our Bible
question and answer program here at
Secrets Unsealed and Some TV. And we
welcome you and thank you for joining us
today. My name is CA Murray. I'm in the
company of our general manager of Sum TV
Latino, Pastor David Salazar.
>> Thank you, pastor. and our president and
founder, Pastor Stephen Boore. Thank you
for joining us. As we said, this is a
question and answer program. So, we want
to tell you right off the bat, if you
want questions asked and answered, then
send them to TV at sums m as in
marytv.org.
That's tvsumtv.org.
And we will get to your questions just
as soon as we can. We have the the
wonderful privilege of being swamped by
questions. That's a good thing to have a
lot of questions because it means one
we're giving correct biblical answers
and two we are helping you as you make
your journey from earth to heaven and
those questions that uh are in your way
we want to clear those out of the way so
that you can be informed, inspired and
um have the knowledge that you need. So
send the questions in. We will get right
to them. Pastor Salazar, if you would
pray. we are going to launch out uh for
our program today.
>> Let us pray. Heavenly Father, we come
before you to ask that you will give us
a portion of the Holy Spirit that we may
receive the instruction, the clarity,
the answer that it is according to your
will and according to your scriptures.
So allow us Lord to be uh used today by
you so that answers may give those who
are watching a blessing and a way to
understand your word even better. We
pray this in Jesus name. Amen.
>> Amen. And amen. Gentlemen, our first
question comes from share, not that
share. This share is from New Zealand.
And um uh she has a a Bible question.
Here it is. I wonder if you are able to
tell me what Greek word is used for
spirit in Luke 23:46.
Some think that the word spirit shows
the validity of a separate spirit that
continues to live on. But I suspect the
Greek would say and mean differently
breathe breath rather somehow because
the breath goes back to God who gave it
and she thanks us uh in advance for our
answer.
>> All right. Well, the first thing I mean
she asked what the word or the Greek
word for that uh expression spirit there
in Luke 23:46 is and the answer is the
work is numa. That's the Greek word for
that particular uh version or verse or
word that says spirit in Luke 23:46. Now
that word is actually used 350 times in
New Testament. So it's not a word that
is only used there or or you know in a
very scarse way. It's actually used
several times and that word has uh five
meanings uh really uh in in the Greek or
at least what how it's translated for us
in the English. So the for example um
the first expression or the first um
meaning of this word is the word spirit
for the holy spirit or in some other
versions they translate it like in king
James sometimes as the holy ghost but
that's one of the meanings of the word
it can be the holy spirit the uh third
person of the godhead so that's one
meaning the second meaning is the
principle the spirit or the this
principle vitality
of the body which is animated. So uh the
rational spirit the power which the
human things feel things decides or also
can be meaning the soul uh the the
combination of of the mind and and the
body as we know the soul. So um or or
the bread of God and the body. Now the
also also the third meaning is the
lifegiving spirit a human soul uh that
you know that means the body that we
have that life experience. The fourth
meaning is the influence or disposition
which feels and governs the soul of
anyone or the life of someone. And the
final uh meaning the fifth meaning is a
movement of air just basically the
concept of wind or the bread of the
nostrils of the mouth. That's why the
word numa in in you know is used even
now for like pneumatics or you know a
pneumatic that u the air that is filled
into a tired and so we can see that
these words or this word particularly
can be used in several ways. I like to
give examples in Matthew 3:16 it says
the Holy Spirit or the Holy Ghost and uh
again that's the same word in Matthew
5:3 where it speaks of the poor in
spirit that's also the same word in
Matthew 12:43
where it says out of um cast out spirits
or unclean spirits again it's the same
word and in Matthew 23 22:43 it says
David in the spirit
um said something so that's and another
another way that that word is used. And
finally, of course, we have uh in
Matthew 26:41 where it says the spirit
is willing but the flesh is weak. So
this is the same word used in those
different verses. And we can see that
depending on the meaning of the context,
the word has a different meaning. So
that's pretty much an answer that
hopefully will help uh you know, sister
Sharon understand. But you guys of
course have more to say. You know, you
you gave a number of incidences what the
Bible does say about the spirit. I want
to give one that it never said. It never
links it to a conscious state after
death.
>> Right.
>> All of those things that you said were
were alive.
>> Yeah.
>> Entities,
>> right?
>> Or andor inanimate because air is just
is inanimate. It never links it to
>> something that goes on after you die.
The Bible simply does not do that. Um,
all of this is occasioned by a
misunderstanding
of what happens at the point of death.
And I'm sort of pitching this to you
because you've got that that impressive
set of notes there that deal with that.
But but but if you if you take what you
have, take what I have, and then you
look at the basic problem, which is once
you start with a a soul that never dies
or the mindset of a soul that never
dies. Yeah.
>> You are you are locked into having to
deal with that soul throughout eternity.
It never dies. You got to find someplace
to send it when it dies. You know, it's
either got to go to heaven or hell
immediately because it does not die. So,
if you start wrong, you can never really
get yourself theologically right
>> because you got to keep justifying your
erroneous beginning.
>> Yeah.
>> Uh I pitched the ball to you, sir.
The bottom line is that those who
believe that the spirit is a conscious
entity that leaves the body at death and
goes to heaven
uh are beholden to Greek philosophy.
>> You know, basically there's this mindset
that the spirit is something conscious
inside us that can live separately and
independently of the body. As you
mentioned, not once in all the Bible,
old or new testament, is the spirit
conscious.
>> Never once does it say that the spirit
can live independently of the body.
>> Correct?
>> Not once.
Not once do you have the expression
immortal soul.
>> Correct?
>> Or immortal spirit.
>> It simply does not exist.
Now the word like uh pastor Salasar
mentioned the word that is used there in
Luke 23:46
is panuma.
>> It's the identical word that Jesus used
when he told uh Nicodemus that the wind
blows.
>> Mhm.
>> Because basically the spirit is is the
breathing breathing in and breathing out
and you breathe air.
>> Mhm.
>> Right. Mhm.
>> Uh and that's the sense in which it's
being used uh here in Luke 23:46.
He gave up his penuma.
>> He gave up his spirit.
>> Puma. Yeah.
>> In other words, he gave up his breath.
Now, there's an interesting variation
in the record that we find in the Gospel
of John. A actually in the in the Gospel
of John. Yes.
uh regarding Jesus giving up the spirit.
>> It doesn't say that he gave up the
spirit. It says he handed over his
spirit
>> when he died.
>> Now,
why is that important?
The big question is to whom did he hand
over his spirit?
>> Right?
>> Clearly to his father.
>> Yes.
>> Mhm. That's why when he died, he said,
"Father, into your hands,
>> I commend my spirit.
>> I commend my spirit."
>> Amen.
>> I want to read a statement from Ellen
White in the youth's instructor, May 2,
1901. This is a powerful statement.
He who died for the sins of the world
was to remain in the tomb for the
allotted time.
He was in that stony prison house a
prisoner of divine justice
>> and he was responsible to the judge of
the universe.
He was bearing the sins of the world and
his father only could release him.
So when Jesus died he says father into
your hands I commend my spirit. What
he's saying I'm committing my life to
you.
>> Yeah.
I'm I'm giving my breath into your
hands.
>> And he's saying to the father, because
you promised that if I was faithful, you
would call me forth from the grave on
resurrection morning.
Over 20 times in the Bible, we're told
that the father resurrected Christ.
That's significant. Over 20 times. One
one example is if somebody can read
Galatians 1 verse one.
>> Yeah.
>> Galatians chapter 1 and verse one.
>> All right. Galatians
>> clearly says who resurrected Christ.
>> It says one verse one Paul an apostle
not from man nor through man but through
Jesus Christ and God the father who
raised him from the dead.
>> And that's only one time of over 20.
in the Bible. Uh and El White says he
was a prisoner of divine justice. He was
responsible to the king of the judge of
the universe. His father only could
release him.
>> Yeah.
>> So what happened on resurrection
morning?
On resurrection morning,
two angels came from heaven according to
the spirit of prophecy. One of them
removed the so stone and sat on it.
>> Mhm. And the other one stood in front of
the throne of the tomb.
>> The tomb
>> and said, "Thou son of God,
>> thy father calls thee."
>> Correct?
>> And then according to John 10 17 and 18,
Jesus comes forth from the tomb with a
life that was within himself.
>> Yeah.
>> But the father had to call him
>> Mhm.
>> in order for him to come out with the
life that was within himself.
>> Mhm. Um so so there's a this small
difference between Luke 23:46 it says
gave up the panuma
>> uh by the way in Mark 15:37 the word
that is used is eanusen
which means to breathe out
>> he breathed his last
>> but John 19:30 is he handed over his
spirit
>> I like that
>> now to whom was he handed over his
spirit he was handing it over to the one
that he commended his spirit into the
hands of now one more thing that and
then I'll be quiet because I've talked
too much already.
>> The spirit is more
>> than the breath. This is a dimension
that even Adventists don't really take
into account very frequently.
The spirit with the spirit we write our
our life identity.
In other words, because we're able to
breathe,
>> we're able to write our biography, our
history.
Let me ask you, was Adam different when
he was 930 years old than when he first
came into existence? He had a whole life
history,
>> right? Let me ask you, when Adam is
resurrected,
um, when Jesus comes, is Jesus only
going to return to him as breath with a
blank record, or is he going to return
to Adam, the person that he was when he
died?
>> He's going to return to him the breath
along with his self-identity.
>> Right?
>> So, the spirit is both. It's the breath
and the selfidentity.
So what did Jesus have when he
resurrected? Was he still Jesus? Did he
remember his disciples? Did he remember
where he had gone?
>> Yes. Yes.
>> Not only the breath that was returned to
him to a body. It was the breath with
his life record.
>> I want to read just a statement here
from Ellen White.
>> She understood this.
>> But even in Adventism, this is not fully
understood.
>> Yeah.
>> Our personal identity is preserved in
the resurrection.
>> Yes, I remember the text. Though not the
same particles of matter or material
substance as went into the grave.
>> Mhm.
>> The wondrous works of God are a mystery
to man. The spirit,
the character of man, comma, is returned
to God. They're to be preserved. What
does God preserve?
>> The character,
>> our character, who we are.
>> Then she continues, in the resurrection,
every man will have his own character.
Well, let me ask you, where is Adam's
character today? It's disintegrated.
>> Yes.
>> His body, who knows where his body is,
but what did God preserve, who Adam is
>> in the records.
>> Yeah.
>> And that's what he's going to return
with the breath. Adam will be Adam. We
shall know even as we shall be known.
The Bible says, she continues,
>> God in his own time will call forth the
dead, giving again the breath of life
and bidding the dry bones live. The same
form will come forth, but it will be
free from disease and every defect. It
lives again bearing the same
individuality of features so that friend
will recognize friend. There is no law
of God in nature which shows that God
gives back the same identical ps
particles of matter which compose the
body before death. God shall give the
righteous dead a body that will please
him.
>> Then she writes gives an illustration.
Paul illustrates this subject by the
kernel of grain sewn in the field. The
planted kernel decays but there comes
forth a new kernel. The natural
substance in the grain that decays is
never raised as before.
But God giveth it a body as it pleased
him.
>> And I love this. A much finer material
>> will compose the human body. For it is a
new creation, a new birth.
>> It is sown a natural body. That is the
body, sinful body that we have,
corruptible body. It is raised a
spiritual body. Spiritual body doesn't
mean that we're going to be ghosts. It
means a a body like Adam had.
>> Correct. with the absence of sin. So, so
anyway, we need to take into account all
of these factors when we talk about
Jesus giving up his spirit. He was
saying to his father, "Father, preserve
my identity."
>> So that on resurrection morning,
>> you give me back my breath along with
whom I was while I lived.
>> Okay. You know, I I want to drill down
on this just a little bit because you
gave us a bucket full and and some
people may be confused. You what you're
not saying is that the spirit is the
identity. You're saying that along with
the spirit is also the identity.
>> That's correct. Although Ellen White
says the spirit, the character of man.
>> Yes. What she means is that the spirit
is the breath with which an individual
wrote his personal identity during life
>> and at the resurrection he's going to
give his breath back along with the
identity that he developed during his
lifetime.
>> And and the third leg of that is the
fact that
um the new body will be recognizable. It
won't be totally different. Right.
>> It'll be just a a digital form of what
>> Well, I don't I don't want to get you,
but it'll be it'll be a better form of
what went down into the grave.
>> Absolutely.
>> Oh, yeah.
>> Because Paul says in 1 Corinthians 15
that it is immortal and incorruptible.
That's what a a spiritual body is. Yes.
>> It's immortal and incorruptible. Let me
ask you, did was Adam when he was
created, was he composed of matter?
>> Of course, he had matter. God took dust
out of the ground,
>> but his body was spiritual. Mhm.
>> Not because he was a ghost, but because
his body did not have sin.
>> Yeah.
>> Mhm.
>> Uh so the natural body is sown and the
spiritual body comes forth in the
resurrection. And in no way am I saying
that God stores in heaven a living
spirit.
>> He preserves the record of the person in
the heavenly books to return that record
to the person when the person receives a
breath once again. And and that is why
the only thing that we take with us to
heaven
>> is the character.
>> You know, that's the only thing. God
preserves the character as a record, I
suppose. And like you said, it's not
necessarily the idea of a spirit there,
but a record of what the identity is.
>> By the way, it's a commercial time.
>> Ah, here we go.
>> Amen.
>> I have some study notes where I fully
develop this and many other topics. I
deal with all of these very difficult
texts on the state of the dead. The
title is misinterpreted texts on the
state of the dead. I take all those
difficult passages, the souls under the
altar that are crying out, and the dead
who stand before God, absent from the
body, present with the Lord, the rich
man and Lazarus, uh you know, the the
departing spirit of Rachel. uh with all
of those texts from a biblical
perspective and because the state of the
dead is going to be one of those uh
doctrines that Satan is going to use to
deceive people. Amen.
>> I would recommend that people get a copy
of these study notes.
>> Amen. Yeah. Very important.
>> This this is one set of notes that's
that's that's crucial. If there is a
doctrine in Christ that is more chewed
up and
>> and and just torn apart and
misunderstood, it's the state of the
dead. And as I said before, if you start
wrong, you can't get right. You've got
to tear away that whole foundation and
re rebuild. And and so you've got a
thousand churches preaching a thousand
different things. And people who are
afraid of death because they're afraid
of a God who will burn them in hell
forever, which is unlike the God that we
know. Uh so these are important notes
and and and well said. Okay, our our
time is simply see if we can get one
more question in. This comes from South
Africa. This is Marie and um hi. I've
been listening to Pastor Boore uh his
discussion of Matthew 24 and find it
very helpful and interesting. Few
questions. Is Matthew 24 in
chronological order all the way to the
end or only partway? Two. Does Matthew
24:23-27
tell us that Satan impersonates Jesus
after the close of probation? What would
he
>> Why would he do that? And three, if a
person is sealed by the Holy Spirit and
receives the latter reign, has his
probation closed? Can Satan still tempt
him? And could he sin? Uh, after that, a
little last generation theology question
here. Um, okay. Um, is Matthew 24
chronological all the way or part way?
>> All the way.
>> Uh, all the way. because of the use of a
certain word in Greek, the word tote.
>> Which is translated then.
>> Then
>> every single time that the word tote
appears in the New Testament, it means
something that happens after something
else.
>> No exception.
It's used uh I think seven or eight
times in Matthew chapter 24
>> indicating that what you have in Matthew
chapter 24 is sequential one event
>> after the other event.
>> Now of course related to this is the
question of why would Satan personate
the second coming of Christ after the
close of probation if he knows that he's
not going to be able uh he's not going
to be successful.
>> Right? The bottom line is that Ellen
White states that Satan does not know
that the elect have been sealed.
>> He suspect suspects that their cases
have been decided in the heavenly
sanctuary, but he doesn't really know. U
furthermore,
the personation of Christ's second
coming by Satan is not intended to
deceive the world because when probation
closes, the world is already deceived.
Mhm.
>> There's no wicked person to deceive.
When probation closes, the wicked are
already deceived. But there's a group
that has not been deceived.
>> Mhm.
>> And that group that has not been
deceived is the elect.
>> So the target of the person of Christ is
not to deceive the world.
>> It's to deceive the group that has not
allowed itself to be deceived. It's
Satan's last resort. In fact, Ellen
White has a quotation where she tells us
the exact moment when Satan is going to
personate the second coming of Christ.
They're crying out. The elect are crying
out day and night for deliverance. Ellen
White states, by the way, every time she
uses the expression cry out day and
night, it applies to the crying out
after the close of probation without
exception. I check them all.
>> And so, she says they're crying out day
and night for deliverance from their
enemies. And she says at that moment
Satan will personate the second coming
of Christ and say I have come to answer
your prayers.
>> So we know that it's after the close of
probation and we know who's who Satan's
target is. Satan's target is the elect.
It's not the world at large. Satan is
saying I know I haven't been able to
deceive them. So I'm going to do this as
the last resort. But he will not be able
to because he will deceive if possible
the very elect. How do we know that it's
that he's not going to deceive them?
>> Because when Jesus comes, he calls the
elect from the four corners of the
earth. Yes. If he calls them from the
grave, from the four corners of the
earth, then he was not able to deceive
them.
>> By the way, I want another commercial
here. Behold, I send you Elijah. I have
a long section in these study notes on
when Satan is going to personate the
second coming of Christ and why.
>> Amen.
>> All righty. Again, very good program,
gentlemen. Thank you, sir, very much.
Well said. Well done. And uh we want to
encourage you to keep on studying the
word of God. In that word is your
strength is your victory, your
overcoming power. You can do nothing
with without him, but you can do all
things through him. God bless you. We'll
see you again soon. Be blessed.
[Music]